une carte postale grandeur nature en
guise de bienvenue à l'Orangerie du
domaine de Madame Élisabeth plus de 200
cartes postales datant de 1890 à 1920
raconte l'histoire de notre département
les
Yvelines le département des ivelines au
début du 20e siècle n'existait pas on n
connaissait même pas le nom puisque nous
parlions simplement de la sénéoise et le
département des Yvelines a vu sa
naissance et son contour en
1968 à l'initiative du Conseil général
position rectoverso a pu voir le jour
grâce à diverses associations
ivelinoises dont celle des cartes
postales du 78 à laquelle appartient
Olivier DEAS commissaire de l'exposition
ce support média au début du 20e siècle
c'était le seul témoignage qui existait
pour communiquer nous n'avions pas de
télévision nous n'avions pas d'internet
nous n'avions aucun média elle
présentaiit qu'elles étaient les dans
les villages dans les campagnes dans les
villes toutes les actions qui étaient
faites il y avait une fête il y avait
des cartes postales il y avait un
accident il y avait des cartes postales
il y avait des mariages il y avait des
cartes postales chacun se montrait dans
son magasin dans sa boutique dans sa vie
au quotidien les cartes postales du
début du 20e siècle deviennent de
véritables témoins du passé elle propose
un regard ludique sur notre histoire à
la sortie de r encour et qu'on va vers
versaill la carte passale où vous voyez
vous avez ça a pas beaucoup changé sauf
que vous avez une seule voiture
imaginez-vous aujourd'hui quand vous
êtes là c'est ce que je disis tout à
l'heure en venant les commissaires
Olivier Deass et Catherine Lecomte ont
organisé l'exposition autour de
thématiques comme la belle époque la
ville et le village l'enseignement ou
encore
l'industrie des cartes postales rien que
sur les es il y en a des millions et des
millions voilà on a 39 cantons donc on
veut au moins une carte par canton et le
target maximum était de 150 cartes mais
bon on a puisé au travers de ce qu'on
appelle les plus belles cartes des
Yvelines et on a un petit peu dérivé
puisqu'on a à un peu plus de 270 cartes
postales l'exposition ravira les cartes
au files les curieux ou les historiens
jusqu'en février 2013 pour les plus
intéressés des visites guidées sont
prévues les 2 et 9 décembre ainsi que
les 13 et 27 janvier à 15h autre
événement à ne pas rater pour les
amateurs de timbre et de carte postal
les 80 ans de l'amical philatélique et
carartteophil de Versailles les 8 et 9
décembre